[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue d'anciens on
parler sport l'émission ne pas manquer
si vous êtes un amoureux un passionné de
sport local aujourd'hui il y aura comme
toujours des analyses des débats des
duels endiablé quatre chroniqueurs sont
autour de cette table pour m'accompagner
présentation aujourd'hui sur le thème de
l'amour à l'occasion de la saint
valentin
on commence à ma droite elle représente
le mieux le mot l'amour elle sait être
douce et envoûtante mais à la fois
piquante et passionnelle et spécialiste
de pole dance and ou bien à de
versailles notre ambassadrice de change
hélène de la grange est avec nous
bonjour je suis ravi de revenir et puis
20 semaines de la halle aux veaux amour
aujourd'hui c'est charmant c'est très
mignon après les autres aussi après ça
va faire des jaloux tout ça jean va dire
ouais pourquoi pas moi on va voir on va
lui poser la question peut-être un peu
plus tard on passe de l'autre côté un
musique c'est un petit nouveau dans
l'équipe aujourd'hui fêtera sa quatrième
apparition la saint valentin et sa fête
préférée après noël mardi gras pâques le
nouvel an la fête du travail le 14
juillet la fête de la musique le
beaujolais un nouveau toujours avec
modération bien sûr stéphane de visée
sera avec nous pendant une heure bonjour
stéphane quand allez-vous pas bien c'est
la saint valentin
eh bien vous n'aimez pas ça non il faut
faire des cadeaux vous faut être gentil
faut sauver votre truc
oh non non non non non je regarde ça
vous allait faire des cadeaux quand même
en cette émission oui bien sûr on va
essayer on va essayer puis je peux faire
un petit coucou un petit coucou très
rapide très rapide
voilà à mon équipe de
nuits-saint-georges de rugby fauteuil
celui qu'elle en a la deuxième manche du
championnat de france
on va essayer de se qualifier pour la
finale donc je voulais leur faire un
petit coucou c'est votre t-shirt 1 c'est
bien ça moi là où ils pillent derrière
blaquière les bacs cher alors on va
passer maintenant de l'autre côté
musique on le surnomme le gladiateur
mais aujourd'hui nous allons l'appeler
docteur love
cet homme ne recule devant rien pour
conquérir les coeurs et notamment vos
coeurs chers téléspectateurs et nous
vient tout droit de versailles à pierre
chevalier du rugby-club de versailles
est avec nous ça lui docteur mamour
comment allez-vous que ça va bien ça va
très très bien pas certain pour vous
alors oui inspirant saint-valentin
petite fête des amoureux petite fête
commerciale souvent mais toujours une
occasion de parler de sentiments donc
c'est bien est-ce que vous êtes prêts à
conquérir les coeurs des ça va donner
j'ai préparé les poèmes et les membres
doline
on passe de l'autre côté musique la
saint valentin est pour lui la fête à ne
pas manquer il est d'ailleurs passé chez
le coiffeur pour l'occasion c'est un
légendaire séducteur avec un charisme
fou son rendez vous idéal une coupe de
champagne
il faudrait que modération bien sûr avec
un morceau de jazz genlis ex-entraîneur
de plaisir est avec nous bonjour bonjour
à tous vous êtes fait tout beau 60 ans
ah oui monsieur d'aig
je suis déjà prêt je suis au taquet ma
petite femme voilà quarante ans après sa
coupe de champagne tout goûté les
bouteilles relation avec modération
alors pour passer au programme de
l'émission commence par une information
football direction le nord de
l'angleterre
pour jean kévin augustin le plaisir hu a
formé notamment psg rejoint le club de
leeds en deuxième division anglaise le
joueur a vu son prêt résilié par l'ess
monaco et sera prêté jusqu'à la fin de
la saison par le club de l'epci qu avec
qui il est sous contrat jusqu'en 2022 à
liszt l'illinois retrouvera notamment un
certain marcello bielsa l'ancien
entraîneur de l'om veut en faire un
titulaire indiscutable
qu'en pensez vous c'est une bonne idée
ou pas où voter oui ou non
oui bien sûr on laisse ses fans de visée
c'est un spécialiste football notamment
vous connaissez les gens qui venaient
distincts et qu'en pensez vous oui non
ben j'en pense pour l'instant il n'a
rien prouvé au psg il a joué 11 matches
mais qu'un but à monaco bon s'ils ont
résilié son contrat c'est pour une
raison mais manquait qu'un but en 13
matchs avec monaco un but en 13 matches
1 but en 13 matches voilà c'est ali
ching qui les pilotent chic et si les
tsiganes où il a joué 50 matches mais 17
buts donc peut-être que dans la
continuité avec bessat pourquoi pas
pourquoi pas pourquoi pas pour l'instant
je m'inspirais pierre chevalier moi je
pense que c'est le bon moment pour lui
effectivement pour prouver le lycée est
actuellement 2e en championship
donc a priori quelques petites chances
de montée en 1re et c'est le bon moment
pour passer le la manche
et justement confirmé la saison à la
boutique les saisons à l'abc ch et
démontrer montrer de quelle de quel bois
ils effet le championnat anglais lui ira
peut-être mieux peut-être mieux à son
style donc c'est le moment d'arriver en
d2 conquérir sa place et pour voir
éventuellement s'il est monté derrière
brillé en premiership
oui justement il va aller en deuxième
division hélène deuxième division
quelque soit leur division
voilà tout moi je n'ai pas choisi les
foules
oui c'est ça mais je pense que tout ce
sont tout ce qui est enfin toutes
démarches pour progresser pour apprendre
et pour évoluer il faut faut la faire
fouler entreprendre donc voilà s'il peut
apprendre et progresser et monter il a
vingt deux ans ce le bon moment
voyez jeune mais je pense pas qu'ils
aient de vraiment mauvais moments il
faut quand ça se présente
il faut y aller faut saisir l'occasion
et je pense que ce genre il faut saisir
l'occasion quand elle se présente sur
tout point de vue leur avait 22 ans et
tu ne cherches une progression pour lui
dans sa carrière là ici dans un club
anglais entraîné par un grand entraîneur
quand même
mais ils sont quand même pas bien ça non
et puis deuxième de la deuxième division
du championnat anglais
et c'est cette vision par deuxième
division d'accord moi mais c'est le
meilleur moyen quand même de se faire
éventuellement remarquer pour aller
franchir la marche et signe un des clubs
de première division
donc on va dire que c'est une marche
logique logique pour un bon sportif que
pour un bon footballeur en l'occurrence
et l'opportunité très bon à prendre a 22
ans il a encore quelques années devant
lui et certainement la possibilité si le
silence vaut la peine de pouvoir figurer
dans un club de première division depuis
qu'il a rallié ça si si si lui ni sur
sur jean qui dit oui justin pour monter
et en faire un titulaire indiscutable
c'est que a priori s'est renseigné il a
vu il a su et il sera peut-être en faire
quelques quelqu'un d' incontournable un
attaquant il a l'habitude de sortir des
pépites 100 m
c'est çà et là il a son style ça c'est
bien à lui
mais mais on peut lui faire confiance il
a si la repérer c'est que et 6,6 augusta
a accepté c'est qu'à priori c'est le bon
pour le faire et pour se relancer
peut-être se relancer en premiership
la dépose de la saison prochaine s'il
monte avec une ferveur aussi qui est
dans le fond dans le football anglais
qui est qu'il peut être galvanisante
pour l'instant qu'à ses débuts sont pas
forcément parfait il n'a marqué que 2
buts en 2 0 buts en deux matches
disputés alors nous allons maintenant
passer au programme de l'émission
aujourd'hui nous allons parler de basket
un match entre deux écoles a fait le
buzz le 6 février dernier à versailles
nous font également un coup de
projecteur sur fabien fitz la future
pépite du rugby à français ils étaient
retenus pour le tournoi des six nations
chez les moins de 20 ans mais avant de
développer ces thèmes on va parler en
val
[Musique]
on commence donc par du handball trappe
et j'ai c'est l affiche de cette 14e
journée du championnat honneur régional
ce samedi 1er février dans une salle
bouillante chauffée par des centaines de
supporters les trappistes entre dans la
partie de la meilleure des façons en
prenant le large rapidement le score à
la pause 18 à 8
au retour des vestiaires les trappistes
reste devant score final 33 à 25 pour
les trappistes dans ce match accroché
réaction il était compliqué c'est vrai
on rencontre une équipe commune du mazet
qui a été peinte équilibré qui est très
libre étaient calmes seuls 2 des
démarches difficiles sont d'ailleurs
partis à la semaine dernière ils
s'étaient préparés ils ont battu
l'équipe tt première ex-aequo avec nous
et du coup c'était un match compliqué à
aborder à préparer et mais on a réussi
quand même à rester
régulier et concentrés en ce moment au
classement trappe reste leader avec val
d'europe prochain match pour les
trappistes le samedi 29 février sur le
terrain de montfermeil quatrième du
classement une victoire permettrait à
trappes d'envisager une sixième antique
consécutif en cinq ans il était leader
avec son leader à égalité 39 points une
petite réaction sur cette victoire avant
de passer à la question sur cette
thématique
jean vaujour est adressé à l'iran
victoire logique
je suis un leader mais j'ai quand même
un jeu le classement c'est la réserve
j'ai fait de la réserve je suis au vu du
succès c'est un vin régional honneur
c'est ça voilà vous venez avec honneur
régionale j'avais dans le désordre
mais bon ils sont leaders bg pointe à la
6e place à 13 points à 16 points
donc pour moi c'était c'est une victoire
logique choix logique sportivement
oui c'est pas un exploit non non parce
que quelqu'un le deuxième cas le
deuxième avec 16 points d'avance bas le
sixième un but à domicile
pour moi ce n'est pas un exploit
stéphane pour moi l'export il en est que
dans le nom c'est tout c'est parce que
c'est psg ondes mais trap est leader et
ce point d'avant coleader co-lead oui
coleader sasp en avance sur paris paris
qui en plus a perdu à domicile contre le
dernier
donc pour moi ya pas d'exploit assez
logique le leader s'impose d'accord avec
mon ami stéphane c'est celle affiche qui
fait kiffer qui fait se poser des
questions mais en fait si l'équipe
réserve du psg
c'est loin de l'équipe des all star des
all stars du psg en balles deux premiers
de l'oiv
et donc la logique sportive est
respectée qui fusaient maison donc non
pas deux pas de surprise va de surprises
en plus tard et 14 matches oui n'est
fait pas c'est tout c'est tout ça vous
fait pas rêver
non pas du tout hélène ça vous fait
rêver cette victoire je suis plutôt de
leur avis non mais c'est vrai c'est vrai
on peut pas attendre
de toute façon on n'attend pas que
quelqu'un qui domine ne gagne pas je
vais aller au résultat de bonnes
surprises
je me donnais contraire le compteur
surprise que je vais gérer gagné attrape
la cod surprise la série car mézague
dont la non sportives maintenant alors
on va passer à la question sur cette
thématique le club a réalisé cinq
montées en six ans la réaction la
question sur ce thème
autant de montées peuvent-elles nuire au
club cinq montées en six ans oui ou non
non non non non ne savez pas tout donc
on va dire non genre alors vous êtes les
premiers à dégainer comme d'habitude non
j'ai dit non non parce que et tel
collègue qui a des résultats et que ça
fonctionne et que ça va et que ça gagne
je vois pas pourquoi ils s'arrêteraient
un si bon chemin
il est certain qu'à mon avis au niveau
je suis pas un spécialiste du handball
mais au niveau auquel il évolue à mon
avis les montées les montées jusqu'à
jusqu'à où ils sont arrivés maintenant
sont peut-être assez facile entre
guillemets supporter une vente sans
remettre en question le niveau du sport
et du handball mais on va pour être
monté cinq fois d'affilée ça veut dire
quand même que la marche doit pas être
très très très très difficile à franchir
le club a été créé il ya six ans je
crois donc recréé où ils ont mais après
on va recréer de nous en connaissons au
plus bas niveau tout à fait mais ça doit
aller très vite je pense que une fois
qu'ils ont des structures
qu'ils ont les joueurs et ça va très
vite et le résultat est là
après c'est la spirale on le dit souvent
dans cette émission la spirale des
victoires dans le sport mais ça fait
qu'ils s'arrêtent pas ne s'arrête pas
après la montée la montée le niveau
c'est nationale ou juste au dessus c'est
la prénationale il ya quelques étapes
oui mais encore prénationale donc voilà
nationale
là ils vont peut-être après commencé à
freiner un petit peu en vue en première
division il faut au moins 7
nan mais première division il m'a dit je
pense que sur leurs ambitions qu'un nom
voilà la liste mais au moins au moins
alors à messieurs est peut-être d'aller
jusqu'à d'arriver à nationale a déjà
pour aussi le construire quelque chose
mais là je pense qu'après ils vont ils
vont se confronter à des équipes qui
sont vraiment certainement largement du
même niveau voire meilleur
et là ce sera plus compliqué je pense
que leur parcours pour les cela il était
assez facile mais spirale positive
serre chevalier ça me fait penser une
histoire de bandes de potes en fait une
histoire d'une histoire de copains c'est
peut-être issus d'une greffe ou en
disant tiens on monte une équipe de
handball attrapons 6 mai le projet
fédère le l'amitié fait le reste avec
peut-être certains qui ce qu'ils se
connaissaient déjà
l'alchimie la mayo qui prend qui attire
et certains sont partis mais d'autres
sont arrivés sont arrivés pour remplacer
cette dynamique dont on parle si souvent
que ce soit à la baisse en deux défaites
ou de victoire elle porte et je suis
d'accord avec jean ce serait dommage de
casser l'élan si l'on nous l'envient
l'ambition et les moyens parce que là je
pense que là ce niveau là on parle pas
forcément de budget de budget dans dans
la gestion d'une saison donc c'est plus
l'aventuré humaine et le talent
individuel au service du collectif pour
chacun des chacun des joueurs de cette
équipe là
ça me fait vraiment penser à ça une
aventure de copains qui dure 50 est un
gros coup de chapeau même si même si
sportivement ce n'était pas compliqué
compliqué mais fausse d'épaulé des
saisons comme ça et ne pas rater les
marches final on voit que dans d'autres
sports c'est pas aussi facile que ça ou
c'est pas aussi écrit que ça donc bon
vent et s'ils peuvent encore monter un
cran
plusieurs crans qu'il est qu ils ne s'en
privent pas hélène ils vont s'arrêter
votre avis à un moment je souhaite qu'il
continue et ans qui se heurte pas des
grosses difficultés
voilà l'avancé face faire mais on sait
que la progression se fait quand on a
des adversaires avec une autre fin d'un
autre acabit donc par contre je
m'interrogeais là ça fait six ans qu'on
a à peu près la même équipe il ya un peu
de turn over mais peut-elle allure un
petit peu de turnover notamment au
niveau l'entraîneur mais finalement
qu'est ce qu'est un moment donné va se
poser la question de peut-être d'un
renouvellement de pas mal de membres de
l'équipe et c'est là que ça risque
d'être un peu fragile donc tu ce moment
est-ce qu'il faut renouveler l'équipe ci
a pas besoin mais oui mais c'est ça mais
après bon il allait y aller vite chacun
les propositions extérieures et c'est
l'agent faudra wind ont laissé tel quel
mais après par des sollicitations
extérieures des événements extérieurs on
peut avoir des fragilités comme ça qui
se crée qui apparaissent donc ce qui est
dans ces énoncés
bon ces niveaux là comme c'est du sport
amateur
les uns les autres ont des boulots à
côté donc ça dépend aussi de ça c'était
qu'il y était là ceux qui arrivent et
ceux qui partent donc à priori ça c'est
ça c'est quand même pas mal pas mal
compensés récemment mais à ce niveau de
sport amateur s'est scellée vie
professionnelle et vie personnelle
effectivement qui qui joue un peu sur la
vie du groupe
parce qu'il faudra recruter quand même
argument ya un noyau de voir se
renforcer wii wii fit pas attendre
il ya besoin d'intégrer des gens voilà
battant des records du monde et mettre
dans l'esprit aussi gardé le même noyau
oui parce qu'ils vont monter je pense
que cette année il n'y a pas de souci
mais la division dessus après pour
rester pour se maintenir
et je pense qu'il faut recruter commenté
sais comment c'est les deux premiers
jours je pense que c'est parce qu'on
fait placer quelqu'un il reste combien
de matchs il reste je crois
sept ou huit matches et encore sonné ça
devrait le faire alors prochain match
pour les trappistes le samedi à 29
février sur le terrain de montfermeil
quatrième du classement objectif une
nouvelle victoire
évidemment on continue par du basket un
match unique en france ce jeudi 6
février deux écoles versaillaise sainte
geneviève et auch se sont affrontés dans
un match amical digne des plus grandes
ambiances universitaire américaine dans
la salle 1600 supporters chauffés à
blanc en écoute c'est ultra survoltée
ouais ouais c'est le match de l'année là
on en attend ça depuis deux mois
aulas a fait une semaine on pense plus
qu'à ça on a oublié toutes les matous
toute la physique et tout on est là pour
gagner
l amicale mais bon quand jusque là qu'on
perd
accor
juste plus d'ambiance et
ce match de basket inédit a été créé il
ya une quinzaine d'années sur le modèle
des grandes rivalités universitaire
anglo saxon au rendez vous oppose
aujourd'hui des jeunes de 18 à 21 ans
mais ça reste avant tout des élèves des
classes préparatoires aux grandes écoles
donc qu'ils vont aller vivre plus tard
polytechnique centrale les mines à
chauffer mais là cet instant pour eux
c'est un partage sa souvenir
un but pour créer pour créer encore plus
de souvenirs les organisateurs ont vu
les animations en grand dans ce gymnase
mangon spectacle de pom pom girls
mascotte d'un soir speaker et star du
basket français frédéric weiss ancien
joueur de l'équipe de france a fait le
déplacement depuis limoges spécialement
pour l'occasion
on m'a dit que c'était une ambiance de
folie pour l'instant je sois déçu
j'espère qu'on va continuer c'est très
bien pour le basket c'est très content
alors bien sûr il ya des rivalités mais
moi je te crois dans ça j'ai vu deux ans
dans l'admiration parce que c'est
pendant le match s'est finalement
terminée par une victoire de l'équipe de
ginette sainte-geneviève face à auch sur
le score de 65 à 46 pour l'année
prochaine les organisateurs prévoient un
show encore plus grands la question sur
ce thème l'événement peut-il devenir une
référence en france
oui ou non on va faire un petit duel
entre jean et hélène moi j'aime quand
c'est moi j'aimerais bien je pense que
c'est un modèle convivial d'échangé et
de partage donc ça se passe déjà aux
états unis jeu après il ya peut-être pas
oui après il n'ya peut-être pas assez de
matches comme ça en france je sais pas
si d'autres états unis qu'en france
pourquoi pas ça fédère d'apparat thouars
comme comme ça fédère tant que c'est pas
vraiment on rentre pas dans les grosses
rivalités c'est du sport ça fait bouger
la jeunesse moi j'aime bien j'aimerais
bien que ça devienne quelque chose qu'on
voit plus près de là à devenir une
référence
faut que ça prenne le temps mais le
genre oui non mais si oui alors c'est
bien et c'est bien sûr on est là c'est
mieux ça va ça fait faire du sport wii
et la gouaille à 1600 personnes c'est
bien mais de là à ce que ça devienne une
référence alors déjà si on fait si l'on
fait le rapport avec mes temps cambridge
oxford
le célèbre match de rugby qui a lieu
tous les ans le var cycle varsity match
c'est un match de rugby voilà match de
rugby qui a lieu tous les ans à londres
atk la mener donc si on fait référence à
ça
c'est une goutte d'eau c'est un match
par exemple ça à peu près 150 ans 7e
rencontre oxford cambridge laisse à 15
ans voilà ça se joue à twickenham
c'est retransmis sur la télévision ça se
joue à quelques dames devant plus de
70000 personnes
donc c'est sûr que c'est pas le même
événement va déjà changerait le nom
parce que pour être là pour être
attractif et puis devenir un petit peu
l'emblème de ce genre de choses
ginette contre auch sa faible au bar
tabac du luxueux village du coin quoi
donc déjà en charge un petit peu long je
mettrais petit peu plus de 2 de peps là
et après si je remet pas du tout en
cause c'est très très bien mais la
question c'est est est ce que ça ne peut
devenir un référent non je pense pas je
fasse marche arrière qui vous a
convaincu les images étaient partagés
j'étais partagé dès le début pour bien
connaître le sport universitaire pourra
rejouer notamment au rugby on a un
déficit de culture et d'engouement
autour du sport du sport en général en
france même si c'est en train de changer
mais en sport universitaire ça se joue
dans un anonymat à peu près totale j'ai
eu la chance de jouer des huitièmes et
des quarts de finale de championnat de
france universitaire donc avec un niveau
correct devant deux spectateurs qui
étaient nos mamans respectives
à ce moment là quand on compare après
avec des avec des des sports fo ne faut
pas mêler sport américain on passe de la
n6 et et à ginette auch
effectivement il y aura du mal à avoir
une sorte de référence mais ce qui me ce
qui me ce qu'il partage en termes d'
avis c'est que je suis prêt à pousser
pousser l'initiative et la démarche
parce que il ya du monde il ya de
l'ambiance
même si ça fait un peu cheap quand on
regarde un dit pelé les images par
rapport à mach 2 étiez ou de hope he
will basket universitaire allait quand
même d'amérique
c'est qu'il essaye de faire comme ça
font ça fonctionne quand même malgré
tout ça fonctionne dans la salle parce
que ça a l'air
ça al'air bouillant s'avère survolté là
et je suis je suis quand même heureux de
voir ce genre d' influence d'ambiance
pour un match universitaire ce soit du
basket du rugby du foot j'en passe et
des meilleurs mais c'est en tout cas en
tout cas une initiative qui qui mérite
d'être poussés de là à devenir une
référence c'est si ça serait la preuve
que le sport universitaire n'arrive pas
à fédérer et à
attirer notamment des spectateurs sur
des sur des matches qui sont parfois de
très bon niveau quelles que soient les
sports tony parker qui donne son maillot
un maillot dédicacé nicolas batum
finalement le fossé plus dans les
tribunes que sur le terrain avec avec
les prépas c'est toujours dans les
tribunes le show quoi qu'il arrive
après moi je serais d'avis de lancer le
que ça devienne tout le temps en fait ce
permanent
voilà ça fait plus nationale là ça fait
15 ans mais c'était la première année
attention que se sont joués dans un
stade gymnase aussi grand jeu gymnase
mont boron d'habitude c'est un petit
gymnase de 600 700 à 800 personnes
la 1600 personnes c'était une grande
première pour qui ça peut permettre à
des pépites de se faire connaître aussi
repérer pourquoi pas là il y avait
notamment fait la nouvelle série qui est
dirigeant à limoges
voilà ça peut permettre à des des gamins
de se faire connaître et de se lancer
dans tu penses que sur des prêts paille
c'est ça soit la priorité c'est une
preuve le problème il est là aussi dans
la culture sportive et études en france
il ya vraiment deux mondes qui est deux
mondes qui s'opposent
ginette faucher les prem's et des prépas
a priori ils sont ils sont ils sont vous
aide est destinée d'études assez longue
son commerce en commerce conscience que
l'économie au sens propre
j'en passe et des meilleurs je pense pas
que le basket soit leur priorité en
revanche pendant le cursus faire un
corps sain dans un esprit sain un esprit
sain dans un corps sain
là où ils assez c'est une chose qui peut
qui peut se développer
je pense pas que
beaucoup de joueurs percevront dans le
basket moi je serais pas surprise que
deux trois recruteurs qui viennent y
mettre leur en prépa certains certains
étudiants sur tous les ans il devrait y
en avoir qui se retrouve pas du tout
dans dans le cursus qu'ils ont choisi et
qui finalement se disent non j'ai envie
d'aller dans un truc un autre coeur pas
forcément le basket mais où le vent d'où
un sport comme ça mais voilà ça peut ça
peut leur donner envie peut-être
d'autres choses et puis ça les distraits
aussi sont bons ils font ils font la
fête au c'est sûr mais c'est pas mal
moins trois mois qu'il ne pensait qu'à
ce match et les pom pom girls qu'on l'a
vue se sont entraînés pendant quasiment
six mois à l'essai méthode pour faire le
spectacle le jour j c'est ça sera une
référence pour les deux établissements
en tout cas les pour le basket
universitaire et pour le rugby ça
pourrait être possible à faire face ça
pourrait être possible c'est après on a
on a des bonnes équipes de deux collèges
lycées à versailles sur des que le dès
qu'on passe là la porte des universités
ou des grandes écoles il ya il ya un
championnat qui mais qui joue jeudi
après midi et qui donc mobilise pas
forcément les foules
donc c'est là aussi on a du mal à en
faire une référence c'est que ce sont
des sujets rarement pendant les heures
de cours sauf pour ceux qui jouent et
donc donc ça s'est perdu en plus c'est
vrai c'est vrai c'est perdu parce que
bon à mon époque la sucent appelé reçu
le sport universitaire ou lycées et
autres il y avait quand même s'il ya
bâti en tant que ça il y avait cet été à
des tiers et il y avait il y avait des
championnats notamment à réguler ce
concept est de 10 et c'était très très
très suivi alors c'était suivi surtout
pas les l'établissement dans lequel que
l'équipe se trouvait donc c'était vrai
mais c'était vraiment j'ai connu cet
engouement de la part de la préparation
des mois avant que ce soient sportifs ou
extra festif oui
petit quitter le sport et les études
étaient très très lié non donc là on
sait que j'apprécie la référence c'est
vrai donc du coup quelque part ça fait
un peu cette liaison esprit sain dans un
corps sain
c'est vrai oxford cambridge à versailles
c'est pas pour tout de suite jean oxford
cambridge collège-lycée cette tour est
pas forcément les universités ouais ça
serait beau ce serait très très beau
garder ça dans un coin de terre
peut-être et monstrueusement alors une
nouvelle question en tout cas aussi
comment stéphane pourquoi pas un jour
une finale à bercy près pas pourquoi pas
ça pourrait être un grand show il ne
s'agit pas c'est en tout cas si les
organisateurs on nous écoute alors une
nouvelle édition est déjà programmée en
tout cas pour l'année prochaine on passe
maintenant à notre page coup de
projecteur
un mot de rugby à présent retenez bien
son nom fabien a vite ce jeu demeure pas
moins de 19 ans est aujourd'hui en
équipe de france moins de 20 ans le
sportif qui a débuté au mesnil saint
denis et au sky rugby a été sélectionné
pour le tournoi des six nations dans sa
catégorie
nous l'avions rencontrée juste avant le
tournoi des six nations on écoute mon
objectif c'est de faire le plus de
matches possibles mon entraîneur dois
m'améliorer
parce que c'est les sélections c'est
toujours l'occasion d'être avec les
meilleurs et c'est donc c'est l'occasion
de se montrer de donner encore plus
encore puisque qu'en temps normal donc
un restaurant essaie de s'améliorer et
travaillent tous les petits détails et
le petit point qui qui me font défaut la
question sur ce thème petit devenir la
future pépite du rugby français vous
votez oui ou non de faire un duel entre
les deux spécialistes rugby à l'argent
vous êtes partagés et pierre également
partagé oui parce que voilà pour
l'instant effectivement il suit le
cursus logique et normal d'un bon joueur
de rugby
il est un équipe de france de sa
catégorie qu'on peut pas faire mieux
pour l'instant je racing 92 il a joué à
massy juste avant obligatoirement y
rejoindre un grand club ça c'est sûr
c'est certain
il est dans une grande progression il
est en équipe de france moins de mots -
devin impeccable après malheureusement
ou heureusement mais ça on ne peut pas
le don peut pas le décider il ya quand
même une belle marche à monter pour
après mais carrément tombé dans le
professionnalisme parce que là c'est
carrément en fera son métier son avenir
tomber le professionnalisme donc ça va
être par rapport il en est conscient
c'est ça que j'ai bien aimé mon essai
dans son interview il envisagea
conscience parce qu'il sait qu'il faut
qu'ils qui montre le meilleur de
lui-même pour pouvoir intéresser
intéresser tout le monde intéresser des
clubs du top 14
les entraîneurs les éventuels pourquoi
pas puisque là on à fabien galthié qui
aujourd'hui à la tête de l'équipe de
france
feiglin confiance aux jeunes joueurs et
ça fonctionne on le voit après les
résultats des deux premiers matchs de
notre cause nationale
donc pourquoi pas pourquoi pas mais on
ne peut pas dire aujourd'hui fabien vite
fait de mettre 0-2 samedi kg ça va être
la pépite sans concileo 110 kg zanis
il a dit qu'il allait prendre des kilos
de muscles c'est pour ça donc on ne peut
pas on ne peut pas le prédire
il est il et il est bien parti en plus
il a un gabarit qui est intéressante sur
un poste où
on n'est pas on n'est pas énorme et un
riche en france
donc pourquoi pas pourquoi pas si c'est
tout ce que je lui souhaite en tout cas
parce que là ce serait pour lui ce
serait magique
bien sûr vallier dans le côté plus donc
oui c'est oui ça peut être un des tout
bons éléments des futurs du quinze de
france c'est qu'il est d'accord avec ce
que j'en viens à me dire il est bien
formé il est dans les standards physique
et athlétique du poste de deuxième ligne
moderne pour remettre 0,2 à vif ils aux
coureurs ce que vous avez par montrer
c'est les images qui avait eu l'année
dernière sur un sujet de l'éminent
nicolas landry le qui avait tourné à
lakanal là où étaient là où étaient
fabien et qui montrait en exercice la
qualité de passe pour un deuxième regard
comment ces gens ces superbes images de
nicolas dans ces deux mois la liste hsbc
en mission spéciale a dit kass et
jeanjean le sais comme moi les deuxièmes
lignes de notre époque
hier et avant-hier c'est plutôt c'était
plutôt des déménageurs de piano plutôt
que des virtuoses là une passe une base
vi est de 2,20 mètres des deux côtés
c'est relativement étonnant pour un
drame c'est rare et surtout
techniquement c'est pas facile pour un
deuxième ligne de ce gabarit là donc il
est dans les standards
il est dans la progression il a commencé
il a commencé au mesnil saint denis
ensuite il passe fait réglées passe au
sky ensuite ma ci et là maintenant le
racing il est repéré je pense ou
surveiller les images quand il était
jeune et il a grandi d'un coup il a
grandi d'un coup la dent sur ces images
ride est plutôt ça a été plus une plus
jeune joueur de ceux de ce tournoi là il
contient les cordes en mai des motifs il
a grandi très vite on a grandi d'un coup
pour convenir les standards actuels de
du post
donc donc il est il est vraiment sûr sur
les sur les bons rails ça me fait penser
aussi un tout bon joueur
d'ailleurs qui est dont le père a joué à
versailles il ya quelques années
retenez bien ce nom il s'appelle
thibault flamand on en parlera on
parlera de lui dans quelques années
parce qu'il est au west actuellement et
il va jouer il va jouer dans un autre
grand club du top 14 n'ont pas très très
longtemps sans père est à bruxelles
cher à un autre membre de la régie et
donc ça me fait penser à ces joueurs là
maintenant dans l'est que dans les
catégories - pépite le terme de pépites
c'est quand il très difficile à sortir
c'est pourquoi pourquoi lui et pas et
pas les autres
on voit actuellement dans le tournoi des
six nations que la france démarre par la
plus belle des manières en tapant
langlois qui lie à iliad est où mon
jeune dans notre formation
je rajoute dans le plus aussi un point
que j'ai oublié c'est sur le côté
formation française aux juifs un jeune
issu de la formation française
et ça ça jouera pour lui pour aller
jouer dans les clubs de top 14 mais dire
que c'est la pépite parce que parce
qu'il y en aurait pas d'autres c'est
assez difficile à positionner ça sera
sûrement un des piliers de l'équipe de
france notamment il est il est leader de
touche avec les avec les 8-18 et les
grands
mais laissons lui le temps de maturer
mais a priori sur le papier il a tout
pour percer
de là à dire que c'est la pépite
peut-être quelques nuances
c'était la master class de pierre
chevalier vous voulez rire
oui je disais à la vitesse d'évolution
physique et sûrement de jeu qu'il a déjà
il est un peu trop tôt pour parler de
pépites mais on va le voir je pense
assez rapidement je vous rappelle oui
mais c'est ça je pense qu'on va voir
assez rapidement
si son évolution continue comme ça à
l'emmener vers vers des êtres temps
remarqué on saura rapidement là je sais
pas
je sais fallait donc racing 92 après 192
mais il ne joue pas il a été dans la
chaire remplaçant parfois mais il ne
joue pas titulaire voilà et en
entraînement la base c'est quand même un
grand club
on le saura dans les prochaines années
et puis on verra qui qui enfin ce qui ce
qui fait après le racing 4,9 soit il va
peut-être pas y rester non plus des amis
d'ailleurs en le voyant on le voit bien
puisque les moins de 20 ans
les moines de sv deux fonctionnent
champion du monde d'affilée en france
d'une belle génération et on voit on
voit logiquement si on part de ce
principe on devrait dire tous ces
joueurs là qui sont championnes du monde
devrait évoluer dans des clubs de tous
les clubs du top 14 et on en est loin
on en est loin d'avoir tout lé tous ces
joueurs là donc c'est toujours pareil
moi je dis je c'est son poste ce poste
va va le plus favorisé peut-être lui
ouvrir des portes par rapport à ses
qualités
stéphane de bizet vous qui êtes un grand
spécialiste rugby je pars à la trouille
me fait dire ne contredit jamais un
rugbyman
alors il a il a joué le dernier match
contre contre l'italie était remplaçant
au coup d'envoi minutes
il a joué à très peu et les jouets à peu
près 17 minutes il n'a pas joué le
premier match contre l'angleterre le
coach lui a dit tu joueras sur le 2 la
deuxième rencontre contre l'italie
est-ce qu'on s'enflamme pas un petit peu
pour l'instant parce qu'il vient tout
juste d'intégrer un finalement ce groupe
pour le laisser grandir et puis voir ce
que ça donne plus tard c'est tout le
dakar jean oui tout à fait voilà vous
voulez vous il venait de le dire il
arrive et il n'est pas titulaire
incontestable et incontesté à son poste
en équipe de france des moins de 20 ans
donc déjà oui il il est même pas on peut
dire qu'il est même pas à la marche de
pouvoir la franchir pour aller pourrait
devenir professionnel mais aujourd'hui
les scores vous a plu je pense c'est un
garçon qui est bien à sa tête et qui
sait où il va je fais
ouais ça mais je pense qu'il est lucide
il prend dans l'otan en tout cas on lui
souhaite
ces belles carrières on continuera le
suivre sur tv 78 ont continué cette page
coup de projecteur part du sport
automobile libinois jean pierre garçon
originaire de montesson avec sa boucle
et son 21e rallye raid comme copilote
aux côtés de christian lavieille
le duo a terminé à la 28e place de cette
épreuve disputée en arabie saoudite nous
avons eu la chance de recevoir divine
mois sur ce plateau ont cours dans une
catégorie de véhicules de série et c'est
pas du tout la même chose que le
prototype qui sont devant donc le
challenge est complètement différent le
niveau c'est un véhicule de série qu'il
faut ménager tous les matins aux parents
pensant déjà là en premier à être arrivé
le soir sans trop abîmer la voiture
parce que tout peut ne pas changer on
peut pas changer certains éléments
mécaniques donc faut vraiment père
préserver la voiture et s'est pas
particulièrement facile surtout pour le
pilote alors je rappelle que jean pierre
garcin était copilote sur ce dernier tac
à la question sur ce thème faut-il se
satisfaire d'une 28e place sur un dakar
oui ou non oui oui oui
stéphane c'est bien 28e ou d'accord
c'est bien voilà sur la rue
oui c'était combien centaines ils
centaine à peu près certaine 28 c'est
très bien c'est une place honorable fils
voilà prêt puis finit donc voilà il y en
a pas beaucoup qui finissent et
d'annoncés très bien non mais c'est vrai
c'est déjà terminé on sait les
encombrent les problèmes rencontrés
28e après il y en a il en a fait pas mal
passé il a gagné notamment une
spécial en 2013 et c'était quoi son
meilleur classement l'association
meilleur classement c'est à peu près 25e
30e eefje toujours à peu près dans qui
se maintient sanctions les véhicules
sont sûrement différent les équipes
aussi mais non c'est bien c'est un
virage et c'est une course auto bélie
qui fait vraiment rêver le fait qu'elle
revienne à part en afrique mais un petit
peu sur l'autre continent que l'amérique
du sud qui est dénaturé un tout petit
peu tout petit peu le nom dakar mais bon
on sait on sait pourquoi ça avait été
dégoûté délocaliser une course qui me
fait rêver et sans y connaître grand
chose en termes de mécanique notamment
je trouve que déjà de passer la ligne
d'arrivée après x il se journée a galéré
avec les mains dans le moteur et dans le
cambouis et en navigation simple pour un
co pilote c'est sale c'est ça l'enjeu
c'est à saluer d'un grand coup de
chapeau
28e place alors oui la deuxième place et
attachant sur sur le papier mais en gros
ils n'ont pas tout suivi et c'est à
saluer parce que c'est une course
extrêmement exigeante genre il était sur
une toyota
parce qu'il n'est pas là le plus
mauvaise des voitures 28e pour vous ce
soit une vraie performance
c'est une hybride c est terminé premier
dans la catégorie t2 un véhicule de
série voilà oui parce que là on disait
qu'il est sur des véhicules de série ne
visons pas du tout le fait c'est
pallincourt square et dans ses propos je
ne pense pas qu'ils vraiment je pense
qu'ils font le dakar pour le finir que
pour le terminer c'est à dire pour
terminer pour terminer leur course
on le voit dans ces propos on l'entend
surtout dans ses propos que
il ménage le véhicule leur objectif
c'est d'arriver dans les temps à chaque
fois de préparer le véhicule pour l'un
d'eux mêmes parce qu'ils n'ont pas la
même assistance que les véhicules des
prototypes les pros donc je pense qu'il
n'ya pas il n'y a pas une notion de
compétition et de course
je pense que c'est plus la leur but
c'est de finir de finir et c'est déjà on
l'a dit autour de la table c'est déjà un
exploit de terminer le dakar
hélas beaucoup qui ne termine pas mais
ils ne vendent pas ils ne vont pas
recherché je passe sur lui poser la
question
le fait qu'ils fissent 28e ou 12e je
pense pas que ça change grand chose dans
leurs dents dans leur réflexion
ils n'ont pas forcément l'assistance
vraiment de ne pas d'assistance à ceux
qu'ils nourrissent facteurs il se
débrouille il l'a dit que c'est encore
plus remarquable parce que il faut avoir
des vraies compétences
et puis c'est fatigue je pense tout haut
tout au long de la course qui
s'accumulent aux français qu'il gagne en
expérience offert mesures d'état cas on
va revoir peut-être ça son premier dakar
c'était en 1997 voilà sa première
voiture forcément ans 21 drakkar ils
doivent améliorer leurs commentaires je
pense qu il est vrai un vrai amour pour
cette course pour la faire tant de fois
sûrement avoir changé dès qu'ils passent
quand 21 ans il est pas toujours je
pense avec les mêmes
ça fait cinq ans qu'il est avec avec
christian lavieille ses pilotes leurs
actions laquelle nous on est là qu elle
parle de sa maman ben c'est pas très
chaud il a gagné de toute façon avec
tous ces dakar avec toutes ses courses
il a gagné en expérience évidemment mais
c'est il sait gérer les courses et c'est
sûrement pour ça aussi qui sait les
voilà justement en 2013
il a remporté sa spéciale un cas me lis
il sait comment il sait comment gérer
voiture à sierre depuis 97 est terminée
surtout des surtout terminer et c'est là
encore une fois c'est là où est le sénat
où est la performance donc le terminer
c'est déjà bien c'est au delà du du jeu
c'est bien de participer l'essentiel est
de participer c'est au delà de ça c'est
que là c'est vraiment une course
extrêmement exigeante véhicule de série
pas la même assistance
il faut de la mécanique il faut de là il
faudra il faut de la chance dans la
navigation aussi en plus de la rend plus
à des techniques et de la connaissance
il faut de la confiance aussi entre
pilotes copilotes
donc c'est oui oui c'est bien jean
pierre garcin a déjà annoncé vouloir
participer à vingt deuxième dakar en
on continue par du tennis la winter cup
l'équivalent de la fête cap chez les
moins de 12 ans était organisée ce
vendredi 31 janvier ce dimanche 2
février à feucherolles au comité des
yvelines une première édition qui a
attiré les plus grands espoirs européens
de la discipline on écoute le président
du comité des yvelines au le niveau est
très très haut puisque on a maintenant
des jeunes filles
de 12 ans et moi c'est vraiment un
niveau de jeu et au niveau physique et
au niveau technique et au niveau
tactique très très élevé la compétition
a finalement été remporté par la pologne
2 à 1 face à l'angleterre la france
termine 5ème vu le succès rencontré
cette année le comité adhésives in va
organiser une nouvelle winter cup au
même date l'année prochaine la question
sur ce thème
cet événement doit-il s'inscrire dans le
temps dans les yvelines
oui oui stéphane de bizet oui oui je
suis d'accord la winter cup cv c'est
bien vous connaissez peut-être cup
je connaissais la fed cup la winter cup
je ne connaissais pas et ça peut
permettre à des jeunes de commencer à à
s'affronter dans le haut niveau ça peut
être un palier pour pour plus tard
pierre chevalier
c'est une c'est une très bonne très
bonne manière en fait de d'essayer de
faire comme les grandes puisque là on a
vu là on a vu le fait que gagner par les
filles l'hiver dernier
enfin en fin d'année dernière et c'est
si les yvelines dont on parle si souvent
sur ce plateau en termes de sport savent
accueillir et organiser tous types de
compétitions tous sports confondus
sané ça n'est que pour notre plus grand
bonheur je pense et en termes de tennis
de pouvoir attirer toutes les toutes les
nationalités sur un tournoi qui
deviendrait référence et une c'est une
chose à souhaiter
sans aucun doute il ya des grandes
choses qui sont passés par appartenant à
steffi graf lindsay davenport ou des
joueuses françaises qui joue
actuellement sur sur le circuit hélène
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez
je pense que c'est un
j'ai dit rien y a
future joueuse en plus international
c'est il faut que cette compétition-là
reste continue eh oui si c'est organiser
nos résidents les yvelines on est on est
ravis on veut que ça reste nous on adore
le sport ici mais on essaie vraiment
divine et les yvelines sont fiers
d'accueillir une compétition qu'il ya du
sport sinon il n'y aurait pas d'émission
oui on s'assoit autour de ces
spectateurs sait comment s'y passe c'est
vrai genre c'est très bien c'est très
très bien c'est donc il y avait sept
pays un jeu lent appel dont la france
voilà donc mais c'est là c'est pareil
c'est l'évolution des jeunes des jeunes
tenniswomen et c'est à cet âge là déjà
on commence à repérer les ans par les
pépites tout à l'heure pour le rugby
avec fabien mythe
le tennis c'est pas un peu pareil c'est
même chose dans tous les sports
d'ailleurs et principalement au tennis
ou c'est un sport individuel est encore
plus de 2,2 de qualité à avoir
individuelle et est plus contraignant je
pense hélas là se sont adressés à
travers ce genre de tournon que on
déniche les premières pépites
la preuve vous l'avez dit ad beaucoup de
grains de championne aujourd'hui qui
sont passés par ce genre de tournoi
c'est une obligation forcément vous
pensez que ça intéresse les yvelinois
cette compétition il y avait un petit
peu de monde dans les tribunes après en
terme de communication il faut il faut
être juste ça dure ça du c'était un
petit peu léger moi qui habite très
proches très proches de feucherolles je
n'ai pas encore revu
j'étais au courant grâce à des descentes
18 mai c'est tout le reste
enfin de base affiche pas deux il ya
quelques communications éventuellement
sur les réseaux sociaux
ce qu'on a vu à travers la fédération
française de tennis fédération locale
locales aussi
ville bon après c'est là on est dans un
sport individuel qui joue par équipe
on n'est plus dans l'optique de détecter
les futurs talents
et puis tout pas mais les futurs talents
internationaux on n'est pas si loin de
roland garros
quelques kilomètres de roland garros
donc c'est une bonne une bonne revue
d'effectif une bonne base les talents se
se déclare relativement tôt dennis et
sur les sports individuels
donc c'est bien c'est bien de pouvoir
les suivre d'entrée et notamment sur un
sur un événement il ya un tournoi
référents dans les ive et hellemmes vous
pourriez aller voir un la winter cup
l'année prochaine je pense que comme des
et pierre s'il y avait plus de
communications y aurait forcément plus
de monde et je pense qu'il ya vraiment
quand on voit sur les images il ya
vraiment
il doit se passer il va y avoir une
tension ça va être très intéressant à
regarder de voir des jeunes comme ça
qu'ils lâchent pas le bout et c'est sur
ce point je le rappelle c'est tu te
calmes et moi j'aime bien j'aime bien
ton bois référent pour toutes les tous
ceux qui se lancent toutes les gamines
qui se lance dans dans la compét
en tout cas le comité les il va
organiser une nouvelle winter cup
l'année prochaine je le disais
précédemment passe maintenant à notre
page débats des places prises et un
public qui répond au présent la
troisième édition du tournoi ea sport
tas de nouveau fait le plein ce week end
plus de 200 joueurs se sont affrontés
durant toute une après-midi amateurs
comme professionnels après deux saisons
tourner autour du hub stone le tournoi
s'être ouvert à deux nouveaux jeux du
football avec fifa 20 et league of
legends jeu numéro un du monde de lys
porte qui vient de fêter ses 10 ans on
écoute
l'organisateur l'idée c'était que les
jeux c'est un peu comme des disciplines
sportives
on a beau être sportif si on joue pas au
rugby on va pas forcément sur le rugby
donc là l'idée c'était d'avoir plus de
diversité plus de personnes qui étaient
intéressés mais pas forcément sur un
seul jeu
donc là ça a permis d'avoir des
communautés trois jours on peut imaginer
qu'un arrêté de cap
les vainqueurs se sont partagé près de
4000 euros de dotation les équipes
pensent déjà à une quatrième édition
la question est simple doit-on organisé
plus de compétitions de heath porte dans
les yvelines
non non à en faire un petit un petit
duel entre vos pierres qui avait dégainé
en premier et jean qui a dégainé en
dernier aujourd'hui c'est la tranche
c'est la taille
moi j'ai mis 10 g
je suis pas la bonne personne à qui
poser cette question là en terme de en
terme de quand on parle de sport dans
d'anciens par les sports j'ai vraiment
du mal à transposer même si même si fifa
20 arrêts sur le tournoi de l'ispor mais
j'ai du mal à transposer sur la logique
sportive et sur le fait de la dépendance
physique mental pour pour pouvoir
comparer l'ispor même dans la tête dans
la dénomination ça me l'électro sais pas
si forte c'est vrai mais c'est le fait
qu'ils exportent dans la vie il s'agit
je le comprends mais je le partage pas
ces accès à presse et je trouve que
c'est une comparaison ou ou une analogie
qui n'a pas lieu d'être
après que ce soit une activité un loisir
l'équipe extrêmement fédérateur et kiki
et dieu sait quelle qu'elle rassemble du
monde c'est plus dans cette présentation
la et dense est dans cette analogie au
sport que j'ai du mal à trouver la
trouver le parallèle de là à dire qu'il
faut plus d'événements bas limitent moi
je dis non parce que c'est la discipline
mais peut-être qu'il y a le public et
les pratiquants pour
là le marché des consoles de jeux est en
pleine explosion depuis qu'ils n une
vingtaine d'années maintenant il ya un
vrai engouement
après ce qu'est ce que c'est là dessus
que doivent faire l'effort les îles et
boeuf les ivy doit faire l'effort
je suis pas sûr je suis je suis beaucoup
plus fan d'une winter cup
supplémentaires qui s'installe entre est
également présente chez loi exactement
versailles c'est pas très heureux non
plus mais pour répondre à la question
d'hier ou si on a déjà qui dit c'est
très bien pour tous ceux qui aiment et
qu'ils sont et qui sont aficionados plus
joker ou pas forcément genre alors moi
je dis moi dis je passerai la parole à
stéphane qui tranchera d'accord moi je
suis du même avis que jean donc j'étais
mitigé pourquoi parce que sur le parti
la partie sport je vais pas redire ce
que dit pierre jeu totalement d'accord
avec lui on a déjà débattu de plusieurs
reprises sur ce plateau sur le sport à
travers l'electronic sport donc là je
rêvais pas là dessus donc c'est pour ça
que j'étais mitigé par contre au niveau
organisation sur les yvelines moi je
suis je suis partisan pour que de plus
d'organisation possible et c'est une
discipline qui il faut le reconnaître
mais draine un monde pas possible c'est
c'est au niveau mondial et ça ça draine
autant sur le plan humain que sur le
plan financier alors en france justement
sur le plan financier ces 29 millions de
dollars voilà donc elle sait rien qu'en
france et on le voit malheureusement je
dis malheureusement parce que c'est pour
moi c'est c'est pas du sport c'est une
activité loisirs tout ce que vous voulez
mais c'est pas du sport et on le voit
parce qu'on a une génération une
génération de 2é sportif lé et au
détriment justement de l'activité
physique proprement dite qui elle
excelle à travers le sport là c'est pour
ça mais par contre il ya un public il ya
vraiment un public est un public énorme
donc si on veut si on veut
les yvelines les yvelines à côté du
phénomène mais pour moi non parce que
justement c'est un phénomène et qui à
mon avis a encore de belles années
devant lui donc c'est pour ça que
j'étais mitigé stéphane je suis d'accord
avec jean classement oui non pas du tout
non parce que vos voyages console je
suis pas pour moi c'est pas du sport ça
mais ce serait bien de surfer sur le sur
l'engouement du 10 sport en parle de ea
sports par exemple aux jeux olympiques
oui donc pourquoi on voit pas à paris il
ya la demande via la démence donc voilà
il ya les pratiquants il ya d'enfants
alors justement terme de pratique en
france il ya exactement neuf cent trente
cinq personnes qui vivent du sport tas
qui se disent professionnel on est le
quatrième pays le plus avec le plus de
joueurs derrière les etats-unis la corée
du sud et la chine
tant qu'à faire de vie sport autant que
ce soit sur des comment dire sur des
jeux qui sont qui favorise l'activité
physique les jeux de danse de
chorégraphies de avec alex mais là pour
moi on serait vraiment se lire quelque
chose qui peut fédérer qui peut
rassembler les jeunes toute ambition je
prends les choses de sportifs et là on
pourrait parler de sport deux capacités
physiques aussi de coordination
peut-être vitesse force après tu vois ce
qui se conçoit s'entraîne durement nom
n'est d'accord jamais là quand j'en ai
déjà fait le débat sur ce plateau sur
les entraînements et l'énergique
quelques dépenses c'est pratique quand
on est d'accord sauf que quand on dit
moi ça me fait mal franchement lorsque
lorsque vous dites que le 10 sport on en
parle pour que ça arrive aux jeux
olympiques comme juge de chaleur
il ya des grecs qui vont se retourner
parce que
ça fait mal quand je dire que le x bow
arrive aux jeux olympiques sais c'est
pas du sport au mois donc non je suis
effaré par vous avez beaucoup souffert
je suis enfin parce que je vois de temps
en temps aussi sur le cet embout monde
du sport de voir des jeunes familles
familles ou des enfants de copains etc
qui passent leur temps à regarder sur
les smartphones à regarder des gens qui
sont en train de jouer et qui décrivent
ce qu'ils sont en train de faire ça me
dépasse il ya un bouquin qui est sorti
il ya un petit moment qui a été écrit
par quelqu'un dont j'ai oublié le nom
qui s'appelle le crétin numérique est en
fait c'est ça c'est les enfants
d'aujourd'hui la td de cette génération
là sont tout le temps sur les écrans etc
et sont pas forcément dans la
socialisation sont pas forcément dans le
sport etc
et là je pense que c'est très bien de 2
de qui et de l'engouement comme ça mais
ça favorise pas d échange d rien donc ça
remplacera pas le sport pour moi
ea sports les deux vont pas vraiment
bien ensemble mais ce qu'il faut en
faire plus à résister malgré tout alors
c'est pas forcément les jeunes byers qui
joue qui joue ici parfum ce sont
principalement des personnes de 35 à 49
ans qui entend professionnels 60 pensent
les jeunes attention ça j'en sur
célibataires les as de la manette pour
pour en arriver là il faut accumuler des
heures de jeu qui font que l'on fait
rien d'autre en fin de compte je puisse
y avoir un écran je ne pensais pas à ça
presque à 100 qu'ils sont dans une
maison 24 heures sur 24 des jeunes est
là tout comme comme des sportifs de haut
niveau finalement ea sports enfin
thierry son permis sur les incas la paix
avec les nomades
quant à ses chances que peut-être les
frusques les genres en vigueur ya tout
juste un entraînement nerveux quand il
ya de la tension monde et je pense que
ce serait mieux
l'activité sportive c'est juste de
changer de canapés en fait vous allez
chercher et encore pas dire qu'à huet
on va passer matin notre dernière
thématique un sport que tout le monde
peut pratiquer également avanteam
bretonne montigny-le-bretonneux
accueillir rendez-vous à des chèques le
18e tournoi d'automne organisé par la
dame noire
le club local de la ville le principe
des groupes de dix participants se sont
affrontés pendant l'événement quelles
sont les recettes pour emporter la
victoire aux échecs l'un des
organisateurs jean-marie aqua d'un
répond au micro de manon varaldo ce
qu'il faut il faut de la concentration
et bien s'entraîner régulièrement parce
que ça paraît pas mais c'est quand même
physiquement éprouvante
même si on est assis
où transpire d'une héroïne quand même la
question sur ce thème les échecs
un vrai sport ou pas juste la police
portent des vêtements je pensais que
vous aviez répondu oui pour stéphane tu
t es comment j'ai dit oui oui donc oui
non je pense que ça fait travailler le
cérébral c'est très bien c'est un sport
comme un autre
c'est un sport officiellement parce
qu'il ya une fédération française des
échecs qui a été créée en 1921 elle est
reconnue donc fédérations sportives
depuis le 19 janvier 2000 exactement 19
janvier 2000 donc c'est un sport de plus
de 20 ans du genre d'activités kiwi
comme stéphane brizé on est plus voilà
sur le mental par rapport aux sports
dont on parlait juste avant je vois un
peu plus d'intérêt que pour avec les
échecs
je trouve que ça développe plus de chose
qu'être là je vais vous foulez sur une
console et c'est dans ce sens là en fait
il ya pas mal de combinaisons et de la m
sport c'est un voilà si on entend le
sport on a déjà eu ce débat sport comme
activité physique c'est sûr que là non
maintenant voilà si je dis c'est un
sport c'est un sport pour moi et
stéphane jean organise un amateur
d'échecs et également oui oui par contre
oui je joue aux échecs
tout à fait l'organisateur de la dame
noire c'est de ouais il dit d'un sacré
peps il vraiment il a eu les pleins
gazon fraîchement il était peut-être en
fin de journée où est donc c'est pour ça
qu'à travers ça je veux rejouer
stéphane a lorsqu'il dit que c'est un
sport est plus simple parce qu'il est et
il avait l'air est plus égale
donc j'espère qu'il va mieux j'espère
que beaucoup c'est une discipline
formidable pour la stratégie pour le
cérébral pour le la maîtrise
l'anticipation et le calcul d'ailleurs
d'ailleurs il ya des humains qui ceux
qui s'opposent à des machines et vice
versa mais ce n'est pas un sport au sens
propre du terme
il ya environ entre 200 et 300 millions
de joueurs dans le monde veut jouer tout
mais rejouer on n'y a tout joué avec des
grands pères avec des parents et autres
c'est une discipline fantastique 900
clubs en france et celles nées de 5000 à
licencier elle est partie au mieux plus
tout en ne me le dit absolument rien
détruit tout sur son intérêt comme tu
disais mais pas pas sportif c'est déjà
la fin de cette émission on va devoir
rendre l'antenne pour aller jouer
justement aux jeux vidéo ils se portent
avec pierre chevalier alors on va
terminer comme d'habitude par une
situation aujourd'hui je vous propose
une citation de zlatan ibrahimovic vous
pouvez avoir une grande équipe et ne pas
gagner de trophées ce sont les trophées
qui font les grands équipe je vous
laisse méditer sur cette phrase à
bientôt sur tv et 78
[Musique]